[Music]
this is star talks sports edition and
for this installment we're going to
revisit the materials world
today hacks and gizmos and there's one
person who we befriended
down in georgia
who's who's our who's our like arms
reach expert on this and he's back well
let me introduce him in a minute but let
me get my my co-host done here i got
gary o'reilly gary neal we always have
you here yeah it was a pleasure all
right everyone should know you by now
but a former soccer
pro
pro guy over in the uk turned announcer
and then we got you over here stateside
so i'm delighted by that uh it gives
authenticity to this sports edition uh
identity and
chuck nice check hey what's happening
neil i do dude never did any sports ever
no but i once uh i once kicked something
okay
and you've joked about sports so there
you go okay
so
i would just consider what role
um
innovation
which leads to inventions and how they
have
influenced
everything we do in this world
especially sports and sometimes
innovations come from just out of
people's heads
out of the ether sometimes they're
inspired by something we see in nature
uh you know nature has had a you know
long run
trying to make stuff work and you look
around you say hey that's a good idea
let me try some of that right and so
our guest this time
this is the second or third time on star
talk dr jug reedy judd welcome back to
stark talk thank you neil great to be
back i'm really making a play to be part
of your star talk all-stars here so i
don't know what the minimum number is
yeah there is a minimum number that's
right yeah above
if you above a certain number of
appearance we but you have a punch card
that you've got to be double digits i'm
sure you get a free formal nomination
yeah
and also in our third segment we're
going to have uh judd answer some of
your cosmic queries that you sent us
from the the patreon a verse
i just created that word i like that
so you're down at georgia tech and did
you are you the founder or just simply
the head of the institute for materials
actually a deputy i was been around
since the founding of the institute for
materials uh we're on our second
director uh now professor eric vogel a
good friend of mine as well um so we've
been doing materials uh as the institute
for materials now for close to a decade
but materials research at georgia tech
it's been going on since it was founded
in 1800s
1800 you're not that old okay so
so let me just i got it i think i did
this in the last show but i have to do
it again material science is one of the
most
important yet
uncelebrated branches of physics and
engineering that there is you guys come
up with stuff and it just works its way
into our environment and then we're
there and we're using it we're uh we're
enjoying it and somebody came up with
the idea somebody thought it up and
they're hardly ever celebrated or
heralded so how come you all are just so
behind the scenes on this what's going
on you guys are the obamacare of science
we are totally everywhere everywhere
i mean everywhere
look through history you got the stone
age bronze age iron age all of these are
dictated by
the key material that was militarily
useful and shortly after that it became
sociologically useful for us to do
things now um
we're less less concerned hopefully
about fighting wars with each other that
many of the materials are now
rapidly progressing into today's society
whether it's
the silicon chips in our computers that
allow us to do these things titanium and
bicycles i mean there's a variety of
different uh materials that were
developed originally for defense
applications that are now
uh able to be used uh
by by
men women and children across the world
so would you say that would you would
you say that because this is considered
the age of information
that we're truly the silicon age
yeah i would definitely the
semiconductor h um
it's
you know everything
we're talking about natural materials
now bronze age stone age this saves that
age so following chuck here
is not natural bronze is not oh true no
it does not occur oh it doesn't accrue
naturally oh yeah that's copper
copper and zinc damn
busted on that one okay i'm gonna bust
you again i'm sorry it's actually copper
and tin is bronze and copper and zinc is
brass the z and the s are switched just
that's how material scientists keep you
on your toes to
not let you remember those things
fine jazz definitely that's one of
that's one of the that's the next course
i want to create here at georgia tech is
material science and engineering of
music cover woodwinds and brass and all
sorts of stuff but let's talk about
sports today yeah sports yeah thank you
so right now you uh you couldn't get
back to your office where where are you
reporting from now yeah uh so lecture
just ended 10 minutes ago um and so we
are today for material science and
engineering of sports we were doing
basketball so we were here at um zellnak
practice center mccamesh our basketball
pavilion is literally through this door
right here um and so we're covering
basketball so talking about shoes
um these are gigantic shoes
and uh uniforms uh the floor itself uh
we're also going to introduce a study on
rim rebound elasticity the measure which
it's it's coefficient of restitution
basically for the realm uh how much i
want it
so that my bounce doesn't bounce out it
kind of absorbs the energy and falls in
yes
regulated by the ncaa needs to be
between 0.35 and 0.5
which is a huge range frankly uh and as
long as your school falls in there it's
fine even the ones on either end of the
court don't have to be the same they
only have to be within
15 percent of each other that's tricky
when you
when you're varying they ain't yeah
but i got one for you jed what the rim
you really want is a black hole
anything
anything
events a horizon
anything get close to it right i mean i
mean imagine how many balls you'd lose
again yeah how many trick shots well
that's like baseball they lose 20 balls
a game no so so you teach class on
location
yeah georgia tech's really uh unique in
that our athletic associations embraced
innovation and um when i was on the
board of trustees i proposed this course
and they said great but well the coaches
will work with you without asking the
coaches first and then i asked the
coaches
that's how you do that and they agreed
to that yeah and they agreed and so we
cover um all of them we
on monday we did track and field we've
done baseball we've done softball we'll
do volleyball later on we'll do swimming
and diving which was such a great way to
learn judd to see the thing that you're
you've kind of seen on a screen
come to life it's a clandestine way of
teaching material science to
non-material science major i've got a
lot of biomedical engineers some
management majors other people that have
never heard of a dislocation or a body
centered cubic for tetragonal structure
or anything like that and i can show
them you know 3d printed butter heads
and how how we how well what's a what's
a butter head what's a butter
hunter oh watch her cut her head okay
thinking about food again i heard butter
head too
and then you held up what looked like a
metal piece of bread so i was like okay
maybe i maybe i don't know about wait
before we get to the putter just yeah
i'm fascinated by this origin story one
of your students took your class right
and
um
came to with the idea
of a concept that you use the
the
lzrd
i would pronounce this wizard yeah it
was a lizard sleeve
and
that person is now ceo of their own
company and you're the chief technology
officer so your student is now your boss
okay first what the hell is a lizard
sleeve and secondly
i think it's great you now report to
your
students yeah the ultimate revenge
depending what's what the what grade the
student got right
mike got an a and he's graduated now so
he's he's no longer my student but yeah
so he came he was a wide receiver in
high school and he came up with this
idea of
in american football american football
yes sorry
as opposed to gary's football um
and and so you'll see a compression oh
wow i see all these guys all the time
where right just for the listeners joe
has put on what looks like a compression
sleeve
but you'll see that there's there's a
difference of the all the compression
sleeves out there right now are uh the
same all the way around it's the same
material so it tends to be slippery
which is really bad for a football
player you don't want slipperiness
better to have died a small child than
fumble the football life
that's what coach that's what coach
heisman said can you tell him that can
you tell he's down in georgia right now
better to have died as a small child
coach heisman was coach at georgia tech
and that's where he said that and it's
totally true oh my god we'd rather see
you we'd rather see you drop a baby than
drop the football
so so wait so these compression sleeves
we've seen many athletes use them and
they usually uh uh
they go over their limbs and go across a
joint typically
yeah and so um those are
the same material all the way around
what mike said was hey what if we made
the outside still slippery so that i
could shed a defender but the inside uh
more sticky a higher coefficient of
friction so that i could hold the ball
better and so with a it's what's known
as a warp knit uh it's a combination of
polyester nylon and polyurethane fibers
polyurethanes commonly known as spandex
um
that spandex fiber comes to the top of
the inside part and so it's
sticky it's got a higher coefficient
friction but it is not like a coated on
material it doesn't launder off it's not
like a stick on like you have with wide
receiver gloves and so we generated
these sleeves mike's selling them right
now we've got partnerships developed
with with major uh companies that i
probably can't say on your your thing
because they're not advertisers um wait
wait i have to go to my panel on this um
gary chuck like should this even be
legal
it is oh
no i didn't ask you judd i didn't ask
you i got used to my people here i get a
refund i get the report yeah okay if no
one objects then go for it if there's
nothing already in the rule book that
says you cannot then you go for it now
if they like that the
sort of swimwear that they started to
use it and everyone went ah ah you're
too good take it off
then that's different but why is that
different it's it's something it's
something it's an advantage it's an it's
some kind of exoskeleton exo scan right
that changes
the dynamics of your play and it's not
you you're not a better athlete for it
i say so it's not resisting
so you know
okay this guy
and then thinks he can just take over
the average my wife says
i interrupt all the time okay no
technology neil is open to everybody
this isn't exclusive to one team only
this is being sold
over the internet to people who want to
use it so i think the advantage is there
for all so why don't we just create glue
man
that's receivers and send them out there
and if it touches any part of their
physical body it sticks like velcro they
used to do that
they used to have that it was called
stick them yeah and uh and they they
stopped players from using it because
they started slathering it all over
everything they're so what's wrong with
that so
that's wrong with that that's nasty
that's a nasty rule right that was the
nasty rules
so judd i have to ask you in the
development of this material
are you stealing a play from mother
nature's playbook here is it biomimicry
or does this a very clever use of
fabric
yeah there's a couple couple things so i
didn't talk about that the outside part
of the sleeve does use biomimicry it's a
special type of fabric that promotes
wicking so the capillary action that you
see in trees for instance that pull that
pulls moisture away so it pulls the
moisture from my skin brings it out to
the surface where it evaporates and
cools me but i've never seen capillary
action in a tree you mean
we know that that's what trees do yep uh
the way you could see it would be to
take a very small straw and put it in a
glass of water and you would see it rise
up the water so the level inside that
straw would be a little bit higher so
what do you say i just wanted to clarify
when you say we see cavalry actually you
mean we know that that's what they do by
looking inside not that we just
you know
you can't go look at a tree joyce
kilmore was not seeing capillary action
when the famous poem was composed about
trees
yup you can occasionally see it if you
cut the tree and the water continues to
to flow flow out of it like freshly cut
wood okay so you mean capitalism because
trees
have to bring water from the ground
upward against gravity so
so that makes it slick on the one side
and sticky for the receiver side because
receivers often have their hands uh the
their the inside of their forearms
exposed to receive a ball
right and you would not want that
covered with sweat for instance it would
be it would be slippery now getting back
to this rule situation was stickum was
ruled out but wide receivers do have
gloves currently allowed and we
submitted this to the ncaa
rules guru tsar kind of guy uh and we
got our letter back on official ncaa
stuff that said hey this is approved for
competition so which because it's
approved in ncaa
high schools tend to also follow
but not necessarily in nfl so we'll
approach nfl later but really our
largest market right now is actually um
delivery warehouse and farmware like
anybody that needs to carry like boxes
or sacks of fertilizer or whatever so
they're not throwing the packages at
each other judd
you don't want to drop it guys we're
dropping lots of them so they've got to
get these slaves you don't want to drop
the eggs you don't want to drop the
tomatoes
that's the lower end delivery services i
have to put a nuance in our vocabulary
here because i think when you use the
word sticky to people they think of
something tactilely
uh sticky and glue-like as opposed to
something that's simply
rougher and has just simply higher
friction but it's not stuck to the
surface in the sense we think of glue or
scotch tape sticking to a surface is
that some distinction fair enough to
make here that is it's not an add-on at
all it's just that the spandex fibers
come to the top of the weave so that
it's a
higher coefficient of friction here but
not on the inside so that you can slide
it on and off without it
you know grabbing your arm
wow
okay oh so now all you have to do is
design a new pig scan
that sticks to the fabric on your arm
and then it'll be like a velcro kind of
thing
we'll put that in front of the rules
committee
yeah so i knew you guys had questions
for him uh chuck
gary what do you have so okay judd
we've talked about products like this
before with with glove designers at one
of the major sports brand and one of the
issues they had was durability
so if you're bringing these spandex
fibers to the surface and you're getting
a lot of contact friction
does this damage
is it durable yeah is this is this
product durable or is it over engineered
do you know do i have to die by one
sleeve
for life or if you built in something or
what is the deal before you answer that
uh judd the fact that you're actually
making these yourself
i hope they're not durable
fortunately we've got it we've got a got
a production partner uh that makes these
you know by the hundreds and thousands
of yards of fabric at a time uh so so
they're commercially viable commercially
commercially scaled um and plus judd if
i if i remember my uh friction physics
where you have high friction you're
guaranteed to have a higher
um rate of of
um what we call erosion
a higher rate of wear and tear that
almost has to be the case isn't that
right uh typically you you would have
these uh you know asparagus little bumps
uh that would come off but this is this
is just a
it's a fiber it's it's a polyurethane
fiber spandex uh that comes comes to the
surface uh and is is
more
um provides a higher coefficient of
friction it's not an add-on material
it's
been
um nobody means all i'm saying is that
if things are sort of
stuck to it they it doesn't slide
that means whatever urge it might have
had to slide is being is being grabbed
by the material and that's got to create
a higher wear and tear than something
that's smooth doesn't it so it's just
it's it's stressful with material
that's all i'm trying to say thank you
chuck
based on our our testing so far not an
issue we've done these industrial
laundering because
some of the
major delivery firms have uniforms and
they go through much more aggressive
laundering than what you and i have that
are at our um
do our laundry and they've survived
thousands of cycles of being laundered
and again because it's not a add-on
liquid or anything like that that's
secured on there it stays we do notice
that our logo peels off that after a
thousand or so
that's that's been about the problem so
we'll work on that not good marketing
there not good marketing where can
because you said you can get it if
you're a high school player or a college
player where can you get this because
guess what i bet you there's a lot of
high school kids who'd be like let me
get on this right now
hello scholarship yeah mamas and daddies
would love that too for sure um yeah you
just go to lizardtech.com
and order away michael love love today
you guys are a little late on that list
we got to take a quick break but when we
come back
we're going to talk about more
innovations that come out of this lab
including what is it a a
a golf
putter that is inspired or borrows
airplane technology i gotta see what
that one's about
when we return on star talk sports
edition
we're back star talk sports edition
we've got someone who's becoming a
friend of star talk an engineer from
georgia tech judd reedy judd it's great
to have you back for and it's not your
first star talk rodeo and i expect to
have many more of these because you work
in in in fascinating fields not only as
they apply to sports but to the military
to all the rest of us who are neither in
the military or play sports so
you're you're a key
source of knowledge and insight into
things that are shaping this world
literally
figuratively so
i got chuck and gary
so okay guys so let me say tell me now
what was what what's going on with golf
um
golf it seems to me
you know as calm as that sport is people
just stand around and they swing you
know swing at a stationary ball
unlike any other sport i guess billiards
the balls are stationary when you hit
them but um how
and why should that sport be so
susceptible to scientific and
engineering innovations
yeah golf is actually the poster child
for uh sports materials innovation going
back you know the 15th century when it
was created they originally played with
you know round
rocks and knots of wood and then they
moved to um goose um
organs that were stuffed with feathers
those were called featheries those were
the golf balls and then they moved to
um what are called gutties gutta-percha
is a polymer
and so just throughout history now we've
got very advanced five piece balls when
i was thinking about creating my course
i actually want originally entitled it
material science and engineering of golf
um but then i decided to broaden it to
the rest of the sports as well as i
started to make it i get it that's cute
you created a golf course
i could be funny too chuck yeah no not
not with that
[Laughter]
damn chuck is cold jack don't play ice
cold bloody brother
[Laughter]
yeah so so you know so golf
has continually just just innovated i
mean if even if you look at the clubs
they're called
used to be called woods because they're
made out of wood irons because they used
to be made out of iron but they're not
made out of wood anymore they're made
out of titanium or
composite of carbon fiber the irons um
aren't iron they're steel and and just
golf so they're still calling them woods
and iron they should call them pass me
the titanium right why don't they do
that right
because they're just stuck in their ways
i guess
this was another one of your students
wasn't it judd what happened here what
happened with your student what happened
with your student all right so so we're
doing golf one of my students caroline
um we approached bobby jones golf course
which is of course um um named after
famous georgia tech grad just up the
road a little bit and said you know
there's a lot of innovation in golf i'm
a material scientist with some unique
research out there and so they we began
to talk to them about additive
manufacturing ways to make putters uh
instead of just being cast where that's
where you take a shape and pour molten
metal into it or forge which is where
you take a solid piece of metal and
smash it and shape it into whatever it
needs to be like a putter head and and
your student is uh a bio medical
engineer if i yeah caroline's great
doctor caroline's graduating this this
semester in fact got a good good job
that's the problem with that's the
problem with uh my workforce is that
they have this nasty habit of graduating
all the time so
now so always flunk them you know and
they have to repeat the class
these are your options available to you
that's amazing
those are available for graduate
students we don't flunk them we just
hold on to them for five six seven years
for more years yeah yeah well my advisor
told me it was getting a phd was out all
about knowing more and more about less
and less and once i know everything
about nothing that's when she'd give me
the degree
here i am there you go
okay
but anyway i don't understand what the
purpose uh what
because i don't know enough about golf
what
could you do to a putter because that
seems to be
the exact same motion for every single
golfer i've ever seen and the ball
is already on the flattest surface that
there is on the course which is the
green so what do you do to a putter to
to create to change that process it
seems like that would be the least
susceptible exact thing in golf to
technological innovation right yeah
and
in a way you're right that's why there
hasn't been too much technological
innovation but we partnered with uh
stuart sink who's a famous uh tech alum
as well that's the best name for a
golfer ever it is think that's what and
he's the best steward i think yeah he's
widely recognized as the best putter out
out there for good but but we talked to
him and there's there's a variety of
different things well um so we did
additive manufacturing so we're able to
make putters with distributed uh metal
throughout and you can see this is
hollow um
the other aspect is the but just to be
clear it means the density is not
constant across the putter or
the width or through its depth correct
we can change the center of gravity and
the moment of inertia and this is just
3d printed with steel we did this as
practice because really we want to use
two different materials one that's very
dense like tungsten and one that's much
much lighter not as dense like aluminum
and then you can really move the weight
around to to
because you want to influence the ball
to roll you don't want is that the only
process that will allow that 3d printing
is the only process that we have right
now that allows this variation of
density
it would allow a gradient right now what
they do is they'll take a piece of these
two different materials and put them
together weld them uh and so it's a very
oh yeah so they'll be able to change i
get it
right you need a billow and an anvil and
a really hot fire yeah exactly
so so we looked at um we looked at
at the face inserts this is this is
really primitive this this was version
1.0 so we looked at um
changing the polymeric uh face inserts
they have different angles so depending
on the length of the grass you can have
half degree versus one degree and you
put a couple together make two and a
half or whatever
degrees to allow that ball to not get
ground into the
surface when you putt the other aspect
you mentioned earlier chuck that you see
everybody with the same swing and that
has to do with what's known as toe hang
so i'm gonna see if this works so this
this is version two uh we we we added
some weight tracks in here on the bottom
so you're holding right now you are 3d
printed
this was also 3d printed we did a little
differently one of the main reasons that
all these holes are here is that it was
too heavy um and so we we did a second
design that takes out just hundreds of
grams of weight to get it more more
comfortable and one of the things that
that you see see if i hold it like this
the face is basically flat
that's called toe hang and so depending
on where this part of the putter
attaches that's called the hosel we have
the first adjustable hosel
out here so if i'm using is that allowed
judges yeah well
gary chuck see the thing is go for the
time fired in a billion and eight rules
for everything
and so
did have they come back and give you the
okay on this job uh yeah so so i just
moved move that puzzle and now see how
it is slanted see how it's in here yes
so so the the connecting point here we
can move it around and based on my swing
versus chuck swings gary swing
um you'll want that in a different place
right and as as your swing gets better
chuck with with practice you can move it
to a different spot otherwise you have
to with all current technology you have
to just go buy another putter or you can
sometimes bend this uh like heat it up
and bend it a little bit so that's
that's a key innovation oh so so it's an
all-in-one it's an all-in-one putter in
a sense you've you've basically made a
modular putter that can modular putter
yeah that changes with your game and
changes with your skill level that's
ingenious yeah we also
brit and now caro since caroline's
graduate and i told you they got to keep
the workforce going so brit uh is our is
the next student that's working on here
uh instead of the face inserts we had a
little challenge with the face inserts
uh kind of making an unpleasant clacking
sound when you put it uh which which
messes with putters heads oh god
i don't write dragon right
how much
you can't even crunch a potato chip
while they're swinging everybody's
already super silent okay
the the people who are commenting are
just like okay and he's approaching
whispering and then in a
sound booth somebody's always they're
right they're four blocks away and
they're just like well he's about to
make it
look at what he's doing right now okay
you know if you were gonna do something
chuck wait a minute now you're telling
me that the sound of the ball hitting
the butter
may disturb
these it doesn't sound good
i hate golf so much right now
i know but you'd think the first thing
they do is just turn the volume down on
the clothes they all have the loudest
clothes and they'll be worried about
that first
so the thing is how do you
alter the polymer in the face because
you're kind of thinking you need a more
rubberized
contact surface to lessen the noise but
if you're putting more rubberized
content in there then you've got
deformation when you connect with the
ball so how did you overcome that judd
because
everybody hates clacking yeah wait a
minute wait a minute judd let me ask in
a different way
so how exactly
change the face of the powder
because of course the deformation
exactly
yeah chuck's got that golf speak really
good there okay it is great i'm gonna
have to practice that when we go to a
break um the
the the polymer itself there's a variety
of different uh polymeric compounds that
can be explored we did this with a
company called carbon 3d that's located
up the street here uh in atlanta uh they
printed this we also can do metal ones
as well and it varies between putter to
putter putter
the whole game of golf is is what they
call a game of feel so the way i feel
putting is different than you any of you
all feel and so the the clacking
occurred when we um is really
due to the way we attach it to the space
so we're going to get back to having
these space inserts because they've got
them currently in putters but um we
wanted to to explore some other things
and so so brit moved to this with a
standard face but because of putting you
want to promote the ball rolling
immediately off the putter as opposed to
sliding a little bit and then starting
rolling you can see the grooves perhaps
going across the face of the uh putter
but they are not periodic they are at
different spacing between each other so
if you're slightly above or slightly
below the center of gravity of the ball
you'll have a different amount of these
grooves grabbing it to promote rolling
you can control it you control now isn't
there a regulation at the length of the
grass on the green
so what are you saying for tall high
grass and slow grass if you're putting
you're on the green and so isn't that
all very stubby grass
it is stubby grass but it can be
differences of millimeters and that can
make make a difference the grass itself
is not regulated all sorts of stuff with
this putter are regulated from the the
width and the depth of those grooves to
the length and all sorts of other
different things
wow
that is amazing so now
i need to know this so you guys come up
with all these great ideas these uh you
know kind of innovations
um
do you own them
sort of um georgia tech the georgia tech
research corporation owns the
intellectual property that i create uh
using facilities at georgia tech georgia
tech makes no claim whatsoever on any
student-based intellectual property that
was created so for instance um when when
mike created the arm sleeve the sleeve
didn't use any georgia tech resources we
didn't go to use sewing machines or
anything like that and so georgia tech
made no claims on that so that's 100 his
this on the other hand we are using
georgia tech this is what the this is
the putter
the 3d uh printed um
the tools are very expensive and so
then we get into discussion and and they
actually did release this ip uh to
caroline as well um so caroline has ip
intellectual property property
intellectual property has filed a patent
uh it's it's patent pending as they say
and that's going to belong to caroline
correct it takes five five years and the
co-inventors there there's a variety of
co-inventors i'm
named on it as well as some other
students um it takes five to
roughly five years half dozen years for
a patent to get fully prosecuted so
we're a long way from that becoming a
fully patented in five years time we
can't we can't afford you
[Music]
i mean all you got to do is just double
the salary that i'm making right now
if we stick right there we'll talk okay
we'll take that off but we got to take a
break when we come back we're going to
go into cosmic query's portion
of this cosmic aquarius edition stay
tuned
we're back star talk cosmo aquarius it's
a material world materials world excuse
me
yes not the madonna more than one
uh more than one kind of material yes
that indeed judd how can we find your
your your
where do we find your creations
uh
go to materials.umgatech.edu
[Music]
uh that's the institute for materials
we've also uh got a twitter um judd
reedy is on facebook and linkedin
there's only uh four other judd reedy's
around and all of them are dead so i'm
the last one around so that'd be r e a d
y j judd reedy and that's
two ds right no 1d 1d excuse me
so gary you got the questions this time
from our patreon members so let's guess
we do see anna verse so let's do it so
this is a long question from jason m in
bentonville biomimicry is a fascinating
field of research both in athletics and
robotics
um
are we currently using it
in the exploration of outer space and
other planets judd
most of the exploration for instance on
mars is is geared at making larger
things now we do have the the helicopter
uh that's able to fly around but i think
what uh jason's asking is little tiny
like insect type
type drones which uh certainly the the
department of defense here in the united
states is exploring uh for for sure um
very small insect like drones i think
the challenge that you would have doing
that on a outer space uh application
some sort of exploration uh will be a
capability of that individual uh drone
as well as powering it and its
survivability in general some many of
the the larger um
rovers are designed to have uh
good power systems and heaters to to
survive the the very cold cold nights
that will
destroy a lot of electronics
but it it certainly there's there's an
extension of larger rovers but also
small things like cubesats like we're
doing here at georgia tech in the center
for space hardware assembly fabrication
and testing that i i uh direct
all right well i'm not doing sports
no so here's what i've got to try and
pronounce this greatly size ziggy
don't be like chuck now messing up
everybody's names
so so you make the sense of this s y z y
g y oh syzygy that's this is no no one
actually has that name that syzygy is an
astronomical term and nobody's named
that so they just that's just their
handle for sure all right so okay
what does it mean i'm lost in space with
that one okay it's it's the only word
where it's at
s-y-z it has like five or four or five
consecutive letters which when written
in script all dip below the line there's
a stupid little fact about it a syzygy
is when any three objects that are part
of an orbital system
have the same azimuth in space
so well an eclipse the sun moon and the
earth are in syzygy um either a lunar
eclipse or a solar eclipse that's all it
is okay
or is i man what it's seizure g anyway
this here's the question take an
imaginative punt at how nano technology
will impact human health
and improve human abilities
go on judd and jeff before we begin i've
heard people not use nano properly nano
means one billionth of and they they
talk about a nano bot and it's something
that you can hold in two hands sitting
on a table it's sitting on the table
that's my that's not a nano bot that's a
full-fledged bot if it were nano size
you wouldn't be able to see it so so
judd how are you guys using the prefix
nano yeah nano is just ten to the minus
nine
so it's a
thousandth of the size of a human hair
very very small structures but nano in
the 90s got a really good name there's a
lot of funding thrown behind it so
everybody's just slapping nano on
whatever micro would be a better
phrasing
which is ten to the minus six six zeros
instead of nine zeros
um so so how will nano affect things
well first of all uh our entire body is
already nano structured so it's very
natural for us to
begin to interface at those length
scales that mother nature has already
figured out over many millions of years
right
now humankind is is able to start
engineering at those scales so certainly
interfacing with any of the electrical
aspects of our body like our eyes ears
tactile senses any sort of uh
paralysis like your central nervous
system those those are there we we
definitely use nanotechnology to
engineer say the titanium implants that
you might have in your hip replacement
we already do that now you've also got
polymeric implants ceramic materials
all of these are engineered maybe not
necessarily the nano level to the minus
nine zeros but certainly the micro level
let me ask you this does uh both you and
neil so does the engineering of
something like mnra does that considered
nanotech since you're working on what is
clearly a cellular level
i'd say yeah
i think cellular is much bigger than ms
well cellular is bigger than
what i would say i'm saying i can
summarize
i can't i can summarize this
you cannot build something
more intricate than the scale of the
tools you're using
you can't you can't right so if you're
going to put together a building and
it's made of bricks sure you can
bricklayers can do that okay but if the
building is made of cells
and all you have are forklifts it's you
can't build it okay so the scale of the
tools has to match the scale of what it
is you are assembling if you want to
control what you're assembling and often
medically
we will co-opt what are already
biological tools that your body has in
order to build or destroy cells that are
smaller than the size of our tools but
in the limit
but wait a minute let me push back so
you're not counting the manipulation of
those readily available tools although
they serve other purposes if you are
co-opting them you have turned them into
so-called the tools of your particular
trade yes but they have to like like you
can control enzymes right that can then
make something else happen sure but
yes but
the enzyme is still a tool in that sense
that is doing the work for you and the
size of the enzyme is commensurate with
the size of what it is it's trying to
make happen so judd are you with me on
that do you agree with me there
yes certainly and
the tools that we have to do to do
nanotechnology um
did not exist when i was born or any
and they're just now advancing where we
can physically manipulate individual
atoms if we need to or in the dna sense
that you're able to uh alter
aspects of it okay so next question zeki
majed
asks would we reach a point where
biomechatronics would be advanced enough
to help us adapt to something like zero
g
without long-term complications that it
carries right now
i would say i would say the challenges
with with long-term space flight first
depends on where you're at i mean
because we spent over a year in earth
orbit um both russians and americans i
think scott's a little bit shy of one
year uh but certainly cumulatively scott
kelly
scott kelly exactly he's on a first-name
basis with these votes
you know that's how we roll at georgia
tech
we've got a great symposium on space
innovations well we've had scott kelly
as a guest on star talk so there
we go
good guy
as well yeah and scott says he's the
better looking of the the twins of them
he does say that yes that's a very funny
statement for sure so
um
we
so so around the earth you're protected
from the radiation you're you're within
the magnetic field so that's keeping the
the cosmic particles from from doing you
harm now if we go to the moon or the
mars or or enceladus or wherever
we're outside of that range and maybe
even increase radiation for instance if
we're sending humans to the vicinity of
jupiter
that i think is is the major impediment
to to life it's not the zero g um that i
mean that affects your bones uh and a
little bit of your vision and other
sorts of things but i think the primary
concern is going to be the cosmic ray
and the other radiation impacts at a
cellular level and that's going to be
that's going to be tough to overcome
we're going to have to build in
mechanisms in the spacecraft to prevent
that radiation from penetrating the
human bodies whether it's or would you
or would you build in the mechanism to
the human
dermis like like what we do with
sunscreen you know we slather that on
top but is there when you talk about
nanotech like wouldn't you be able to
you know figure out a way to put a
barrier underneath your like fourth
layer of uh of skin there
potentially this sunscreen works because
the wavelength of ultraviolet light
whereas the wavelength of these cosmic
particles is
vastly different um that it may not be
able to prevent um but you know that's a
that's a really good good concept robert
bork has asked is there any organism
that biomimicry could replicate to take
on climate change
that would be better than the possible
technology advancement we could make i
just really like the change of heart
that robert borg has last time i saw him
and he was a strongly conservative
supreme court
and now for him to be concerned about
climate change i mean that's i'm really
glad he's picked up some science books
and put down the law
um see people change yeah everybody can
change it shows that um
so is there an organism well the the
problem with climate change is that
we're changing the carbon inside the
earth into gaseous carbon uh carbon
dioxide carbon monoxide which is
creating uh differences in temperature
both high and cold you know you don't
call it global warming anymore because
it's both high and low so
the the the ability to store that carbon
dioxide or do something with it would be
would be great so you can pump it into
the ocean the bottom of the ocean they
say but then that makes the ocean acidic
and is no good for the the
fish um or you can pump it into old
wells like caves and that sort of thing
and hopefully it'll get dissolved back
into the rocks right or you can let
trees pop it down into basalt yeah yeah
trees
trees convert the carbon dioxide on
their own but the vast majority of
of uh conversion is actually from
plankton in the ocean as opposed to like
the rain forest certainly cutting down
the rainforest is no good
from a perspective of sustainability
absorbing that but if you could
engineer an algae-like substance um that
would be a very useful
material to
to to convert that co2 into say oxygen
which which could be useful now
converting too much into oxygen has its
own trouble as well so earth is at a
really nice gold deluxe point we're not
like venus which has way too much
carbon
uh in greenhouse gases and not like mars
which has hardly any at all we're at
kind of a nice point but the problem is
mars is basically 100 percent co2
there's just very little of it very
that's 10 years right right so all the
gas that is there is actually greenhouse
gas but it can't trap the heat because
it's too thin too thin i have an
atmosphere so but really is what you're
saying is the idea
some mitigation might happen through
capture but the real deal is we have to
stop putting carbon into the atmosphere
we got to stop with the carbon we got to
stop with the methane these greenhouse
gases that were pumping into the
atmosphere on such a uh gigaton basis we
got to stop that but clearly
bork doesn't want to do that he wants he
wants judd to invent something that he
can keep putting carb in the air and
then judd takes it out this is let me
take the whole point of the question
right yeah yeah yeah i think just the
the the production of the of the co2 uh
needs to slow down and people say well
volcanoes you have a whole bunch of co2
but you can very easily track the the
development of humanity um and the the
emissions and sea of direct correlation
it's very it's it's very clear when you
plot it and it's not judd we know that
we're trying to get you to fix it you
know that you know we'll work with it
again i'm not a biologist so so i'll be
i'm not biologist jim dude
i'm an engineer jim
jim
certainly mechanisms of catalysis where
you convert one material say co2 to some
other material that becomes beneficial
for instance as neil was mentioning uh
for mars they're considering converting
that co2 uh to rocket fuel you bring
along uh some additional components
specifically the hydrogen and you can do
a reaction to take the co2 and the
hydrogen and make methane and then you
can burn that
which
will help you get off the surface of
mars or hop around the surface of mars
as the case may be
okay
so what you're saying is
we need you coming and going in our
sports in our space exploration and even
in our survival i just ask your readers
to look around themselves right now or
listeners to to look around themselves
and there's there's glasses there's
metals there's they'll call them
plastics don't allow my students to do
that we call them polymers um and then
all of those have been engineered even
wood
is engineered to a degree from a shaping
perspective and some is preferentially
planted all right guys i think we're
going to have to call it quits there but
the lesson here is that we need judd
for all of our celebrations of
everything
yeah once
we'll make it a hundred bucks now
all right we'll talk
i just need to talk we have scratched
the surface we'll get my people call
your people jed make that happen
all right guys uh
judd it's been really good to have you
this second or is it third time on this
program and th this will happen again
for sure and we'll and we'll have you
cross over into our uh star talk
flagship and talk about just a broader
conversation about materials and
civilization we got this all right chuck
gary always good to have you always
thank you all right guys
this has been star talk sports edition
it's a materials
neil degrasse tyson here you're a
personal astrophysicist keep looking up
[Music]